as for my thought about stagflation  look  when there's a lot of debt  and there's a lot of people holding debt  as an asset  and the central bank wants to get the  economy going  what they do is they print money and it  devalues the value money and the  trade-off between  inflation which comes from printing a  lot of money  and  stagnation which comes from it's a  burden is a difficult trade-off for the  federal reserve or any central bank so  yes i think we're in a period of  stagflation but the most important thing  i would like you to do is understand the  mechanics behind it so that as things  change i'm not just giving you the  answer i don't want to just give you the  fish i want to teach people how to fish  and so i'd recommend that you go to my  30-minute video how the economic machine  works because in 30 minutes you'll get a  lot more than i can give you in this two  minutes